The security parameters for
type of traffic.
For example all HTTP
connections from host A to
B are described in
a security association.
Security association is asymmetric.
For example for TCP connection
from A to B, we need one SA for
traffic from A to B, and
another SA for traffic from B to A.
An N host may need many SA's, and
it uses an SA database to store them.
Each SA has a unique index, and this
is the Security Parameter Index or SPI.
The SPI is included in an algorithm
packet, so that the receiver can
use it to look up the SA to unprocess,
for example, to decrypt the packet.
For example, when A and
B agree on the security parameters,
both sides will store the same
SA to describe these parameters.
And a unique index for
B's copy of the SA is sent to A, so
that A can store this SPI in its SA.
Then when A process the packet, it uses
the parameters defined in this SA, and
also includes this SPI so that P
can unprocess the packet correctly.
The security perimeters define the
security mechanisms, and the determined
by the security policies, which
are stored in a security policy database